-Republicans are rushing
to a place retiring
Supreme Court Justice
Anthony Kennedy
while simultaneously working to
stop the Russian investigation.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump held yet another
campaign rally last night
in North Dakota,
his third rally in a week.
Now, we've been calling these
rallies public therapy sessions,
but it was never more true
than it was last night.
Watch as Trump airs
his deepest insecurities
about not being seen
as smart, rich, or popular.
-I meet these people.
They call them the elite.
These people.
I look at them,
I say, "That's elite?"
We got more money.
We got more brains.
We got better houses,
apartments.
We got nicer boats.
We're smarter than they are,
and they say the elite.
We're the elite!
And I thought
that was so brilliant.
I said, "Oh, I am so smart.
I am the smartest person."
My uncle was a great professor
at MIT for 40 years.
Can you believe?
40 years.
I said,
"But I'm smarter than him.
I'm smarter than anybody."
A thing comes out, a big poll,
and a couple of polls,
a number of polls that
he's the most powerful,
most popular Republican
in the history of the party.
-Oh, my God, dude,
get a therapist.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
I know they're cheap,
but get a therapist.
Trump is like a guy at a bar
who acts as his own wingman.
"My buddy thinks you're cute.
He's smart and handsome
and popular, and he's me."
[ Laughter and applause ]
But you know what Trump says --
he's smarter than anybody,
and he had a chance
to show off those smarts
while talking about the complex
issue of trade during his rally.
Trump was defending his tariffs.
Now, this is Trump's thing.
It's his big issue,
the thing he claims
to be an expert on,
yet when his aides
slipped him a note
during the rally
about Canadian wheat practices,
he seemed confused.
-I'll tell you, John and Kevin
gave me something --
they just told me --
Canadian wheat markets
consistently discriminate
against the United States wheat
by grading it as feed.
Do you know what that means?
They know what it means.
I don't know
what the hell it means.
I just know it's a bad deal.
What the hell does that mean?
Yeah.
-Great, that clears it up.
[ Laughter ]
Also, he yells out
"Canadian wheat"
like he's guessing
in Pictionary.
"Canadian wheat!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Only Trump could brag
that he's smarter than anybody,
and then, in the same speech,
admit that he has no idea
what he's talking about.
He's like a doctor looking
down at you before surgery
and says, "Don't worry.
I'm the best surgeon
in the world.
Now just tell me, uh,
what does a kidney look like?"
[ Laughter ]
And while he was nursing
his various obsessions,
Trump decided
to return to another one,
perhaps his greatest obsession,
Hillary Clinton,
during a rant, comparing the
size of his crowds to hers.
-If crooked Hillary
would've won this election,
and if she came here, which is
about a zero percent chance,
after the election,
she'd have 200 people
in a conference room
in a small hotel.
And let me tell you,
if our opponent,
our wonderful opponent,
when is she gonna get over it?
[ Laughter ]
When does she get over it?
-When is "she"
gonna get over it?
[ Laughter and applause ]
If you're still
asking that question
20 months after the election
you won,
you're the person
who's not over it.
Trump's like a guy
texting his ex two years
after they broke up, "Why can't
you stop thinking about me?"
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
While Trump is obsessing
over Hillary or his popularity,
he also seems to have found
a new hobby horse --
how much --
Bear with me here.
How much rich guys love rockets.
He's mentioned it multiple times
just in the last week,
while discussing
his plans for NASA,
including twice yesterday.
-I said, listen,
you got rich guys,
for whatever reason,
they love rockets.
I said, "Lease them the land.
Charge them a lot.
But let's do it that way.
That's a lot better.
We're like a landlord."
We have all these rich guys,
they love rockets.
They're all sending up --
Bezos and Elon Musk
and all of them,
they love the rocket business.
Let them --
Just rent it to them
for a lot of money
and let them play.
You know, they need our land.
It's good to be
in the real-estate business.
They need our land.
You know, we have these rich
guys, they love these rockets.
I said, "Lease them the land.
Charge them a lot.
They just want to send rockets."
But I look at it with Bezos,
with Elon Musk --
they all love rockets.
-He sounds like a stand-up comic
trying out a new bit.
[ Laughter ]
"What's the deal
with rich guys and rockets?!"
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Seriously, though, why on Earth
would anyone want
their own personal rocket?
I mean, sure,
things are bad right now,
but it's not like
anyone actually wishes
they could blast themselves
into outer space, right?
-We're following
major breaking news --
President Trump getting another
opportunity to put his stamp
on the United States
Supreme Court
for decades to come.
Justice Anthony Kennedy
announcing his retirement
a few hours ago.
-Hey, honey, it's me.
Uh, meet me at the launch pad
in T-minus 20 minutes.
No, don't bring the dog!
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
So Donald
"Little Rocket Man" Trump
will now have the chance
to nominate
a second Supreme Court Justice
who will shape the future of
everything from gay rights
to voting rights to Roe v. Wade.
Trump, of course, is elated
that he gets to pick a second
Supreme Court Justice
who could help
cement his legacy.
And he made that clear yesterday
when he was meeting
with the president of Portugal.
But right off the bat,
he had to go and make it weird.
-If you don't mind, I'll
just make a quick statement.
A man I also
have great respect for,
Justice Anthony --
You know
who I'm talking about --
Justice Kennedy
will be retiring.
-He definitely forgot Kennedy's
last name for a second.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Justice Anthony --
you know who I'm talking about.
Old guy, glasses.
You know him, black robe."
How do you forget
the name Kennedy?
It's one of the most famous
names in American history.
Is that why Trump puts his names
on all his buildings,
so he won't forget it?
My name is Donald --
Donald...Tower.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Now, if you remember,
Republicans stole
a Supreme Court seat
from President Obama
by staging an unprecedented
blockade of Obama's choice
to fill the seat,
Merrick Garland.
They claimed back then
that the American people
should get to weigh in during
the presidential election,
which was, at the time,
nine months away.
-The American people should
be afforded the opportunity
to weigh in.
-We think
that the American people
need a chance
to weigh in on this issue.
-It ought to be put off, out
of this toxic arena right now
and put off
until after the election.
-This should be a decision
for the people, George.
Let the election decide it.
-Let's let
the American people decide.
-There you go -- McConnell said,
"Let the people decide."
So now that we're four months
away from an election,
I'm sure McConnell,
a man of his word,
will follow the rule he made up
and hold off the vote
until after the election.
And I'm just kidding.
McConnell is totally
full of [bleep]
-We will vote to confirm
Justice Kennedy's
successor this fall.
It's imperative that
the president's nominee
be considered fairly.
-Considered fairly?
You refused to even meet
with Merrick Garland.
Look at that sweet man.
That's like refusing to pet
a Golden Retriever.
"No, thank you.
I prefer a rattlesnake."
[ Laughter ]
"I'd like to pet
a good ol' rattlesnake."
[ Laughter ]
"Come here now.
N-Nice snake."
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
Here's the lesson.
The GOP isn't operating
on arguments or principles.
They don't care about being
called hypocrites or liars.
Hypocrisy isn't their weakness,
it's their platform.
We saw that yet again during a
Congressional hearing
on the Russia investigation
today.
Remember, Republicans
spent millions of dollars
over four years
investigating Benghazis
and came up with nothing.
And yet today,
they basically yelled
at Deputy Attorney General
Rod Rosenstein
to end the Russia investigation.
Here's retiring GOP Congressman
Trey Gowdy freaking out
at Rosenstein today.
-We're two years
into this investigation,
we're a year and a half
into the presidency,
we're over a year
into Special Counsel.
There is a presumption of guilt.
There's a desire
by Democrat Senators
to fundraise
off of your investigation.
More than 60 Democrats
have already voted to proceed
with impeachment
before Bob Mueller
has found a single,
solitary damn thing!
More than 60 have voted to
move forward with impeachment!
And he hasn't
presented his first finding!
If you have evidence
of wrongdoing
by any member
of the Trump campaign,
present it
to the damn grand jury.
Whatever you got,
finish it the hell up.
-What's up with Trey Gowdy?
I mean, look at him --
loose tie, messy hair.
He looks like he's about
to be cut off by the bartender.
"They're trying to impeach him!"
[ Laughter ]
Of course Gowdy's the same guy
who dragged Hillary Clinton
in front of a committee to
testify about Benghazi
during
the presidential campaign.
And even he admitted
after that hearing
that he didn't
learn anything new.
-Well, when you say knew today,
we knew some of that already.
We knew about the e-mails.
In terms of her testimony,
I don't know that she testified
that much differently today
than she has previous times
she's testified, so...
I'd have to go back
and look at the transcript.
-Go back
and look at the transcript?
Even the transcript
would be fed up.
[ Laughter ]
Establishment Democrats
need to learn that Republicans
don't care
about being hypocrites.
It's just raw politics.
Trump doesn't care for your
respect for rules or norms.
In fact, there's only one thing
Trump does
seem to deeply care about.
-Rich guys, they love rockets.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]